[Musique]
Thierry Mandon le secrétaire d'État
chargé de la réforme de l'État et
l'invité de preuve par 3 bonsoir et
merci d'être avec nous donc pour ce
rendez-vous de Public Sénat avec lafp
edymion avec Karine perz cette semaine
de l'agence France- presse nous
évoquerons la situation politique
l'exécutif face à un divisé et qui vient
d'ailleurs de voter avec peine le budget
avec pinarna ensuite DEP Sénat nous
évoquerons votre action ministériel
simplification et même révolution
informatique nous en parlerons tout à
l'heure d'abord Thierry Mandon l'orreur
diihadiste avec la découverte qu'un
voire deux jeunes Français peuvent se
transformer en bourreau couteau à la
main et puis donc poser pour une vidéo
de propagande du groupe état islamique
où trouver l'explication de cette dérive
monstrueuse donc chez des compatriotes
qui n'ont pas 30
ans dans des explications
probablement psychologique de trouble
d'identité qui
naissent dans des milieux sociaux très
diverses très divers ou très diverse qui
avec des des alertes des signaux
d'alertte qui probablement fonctionnent
pas ou pas suffisamment quand l'enfance
l'adolescence et puis l'âge adulte
arrive et puis avec l'effet Internet et
le le capacité à la fois propagandiste
mais aussi déviationniste de d'outil
internet c'est la produit des deux
trouble d'identité et nouveau moyens
technologique de communication pour le
pire là des problèmes évidemment c'est
le retour le retour de ces jeunes
djihadistes qu'en fait-on quand ils
reviennent en France B d'abord il faut
rappeler il compris de leur rappeler que
la plupart reviennent pas la plupart
succombe au combat qu'ils ont choisi et
très souvent ils ont une vision un peu
idylique du martyre comme ils le disent
mais très souvent ça se termine
d'ailleurs Marine Le Pen dit qu'elle
préfère ne pas les voir revenir les voir
mourir sur le terrain faut aller jusque
là mais en tout cas il est clair que
c'est ce qui arrive très souvent quant à
ceux qui reviennent le ministre de
l'Intérieur a développé un plan tout à
fait précis de vigilance aux frontières
d'interpellation systématique de de tous
ceux qui ont été entre guillemets tracés
et même de de d'incarcération chaque
fois que cela est nécessaire s bien sûr
sous mandat judiciaire alors dans
l'actualité également il y a l'attaque
sanglante d'une synagogue à Jérusalem
avec un engrenage qui pourrait avoir on
le sait des conséquences hors d'Israël
également est-ce que le contexte selon
vous est favorable au vote à l'assemblée
vous étiez récemment encore le
porte-parole du groupe PS d'une
résolution donc pour la reconnaissance
de l'État palestinien écoutez en tout
cas est-ce que c'est la bonne manière
alors et le bon moment un point
d'analyse tout nî avec l'échec des pour
parler de paix au mois d'avril entre les
Israéliens les Palestiniens sous
autorité américaine et depuis ce moment
on a ce ce que René Girard dans un livre
fameux appelle la montée aux extrêmes
c'est-à-dire finalement une succession
de part et d'autres de de de de de
d'exaction ou de vengeance et on se
demande comment ça s'arrête donc et on
sait pas comment ça peut s'arrêter et
pour que ça s'arrête il faut que la
diplomatie reprenne ses droits la
diplomatie du face- àface entre
israélien et palestinien est dans une
impass peut-être que des initiatives
comme celles qu'ont pris les Suédois
comme celles que vont prendre
probablement les parlementaires français
en appui vous voulez dire pas si non il
faut mesurer c'est pas parce que les
parlementaires français vont voter
éventuellement la la reconnaissance de
l'État palestinien que la paix va
arriver mais c'est c'est des signaux
d'alerte s' le si les parlementaires
l'envisagent aujourd'hui alors que
jusqu'à maintenant ils ne l'avaient pas
fait c'est qu'il se rend bien compte
qu'il faut trouver les moyens de poser
cette spirale infernale alors
l'actualité à l'assemblée avant ce vote
donc qui est prévu le le 28 novembre
c'est c'est le vote du budget et on voit
une majorité qui est toujours aussi peu
enthousiaste alors ça c'est c'est
extraordinaire on nous annonce à chaque
fois qu'on va se casser la figure et
quand les votes ont lieu d'abord les
tous les textes passent quel que soit
les oppositions les réticences y compris
parfois de certains de des collègues de
la majorité on nous dit ah bah oui mais
c'est passé de justesse c'est passé il y
a pas eu de motion de procédure il y a
pas eu de 493 il y a pas eu de vote
bloqué il y a pas eu de motion d'urgence
c'est passé normalement et donc le le
budget a ét voté par il y a quand même
un noyau d'opposants qui s'incrustent en
quelque sorte he qui la fois se fixe
donc dans ses contours he là il y a je
crois de deux voix de moins que lors du
de la partie recette du budget mais qui
en même temps ne s'étend pas donc il y a
une opposition mais très limitée qui
n'empêche pas le vote des alors il y
avait également devant l'Assemblée cette
fois une opposition assez limité
quelques centaines de militants de la
CGT que répondez-vous à Thierry Lepan
qui était là lui aussi pour qui tous
ceux qui ont voter à gauche pour un vrai
changement sont déçus aujourd'hui
écoutez d'AB bon c'était pas un
mouvement de masse hein préc vous avez
bien fait de le préciser ça ça veut bien
dire que moi j'ai pas jugé les
plateformes revendicatives de la CGT
mais en tout cas les positions qui
défendent sont pas de nature à à
rassembler très très largement je crois
deuxièmement qu'il faut pas sous-estimer
parce qu'il n'exprime pas un sentiment
qu' est largement ressenti le le fait
que les gens qui ont voté pour un vrai
changement sont déçus bah il suffit de
regarder les codes de popularité du
gouvernement tant que les résultats
économiques et sociaux ne sont pas là il
est clair que l'enthousiasme est pas à
son comble donc il n'empêche que on peut
pas compter
la puissance du changement qui est à
l'œuvre depuis 2 ou 3 ans d'ailleurs
dans tous les domaines c'est vrai dans
la politique de soutien aux entreprises
ce qui peut ici ou là préoccuper
certains syndicats mais c'est vrai aussi
sur un certain nombre de droits sociaux
qui ont été votés sur les les les les
les questions de réforme de la formation
professionnelle l'accord national inter
entreprise qui qui permet à la fois de
garder sauvegarder l'emploi quand
l'entreprise a des moments difficiles
bref il y a un changement qui est en
cours le problème c'est les résultats de
ce changement qui sont
pasés donc il y a des impatiences qu' a
des contestations tant que les résultats
sont pas là ça peut se comprendre ce qui
est sûr c'est que les les les les les
partenaires sociaux comme les Français
doivent être convaincu d'une part que le
gouvernement sait ce qu'il fait il a
fait un choix auquel il se tient et tout
particulièrement le président de la
République et le Premier ministre quoi
qu'il arrive quoi qu'il arrive il y a y
a une double crise quoi qu'il arrive il
y a une double crise il y a une crise
d'offre de long terme c'est-à-dire que
nos entreprises ne sont pas assez
compétitives il faut leur restituer de
la compétitivité partout moyen et il y a
des problèmes ponctuels de demande de
court terme qui nécessitent que
peut-être par rapport à une trajectoire
de réduction des déficit qu'on avait
envisagé il faut un petit peu ralentir
le rythme un petit peu faire baisser la
pente sans renoncer à la réduction des
déficit vous vous parlez des partenaires
sociaux il faut dire un mot du patronat
puisque lui aussi tient un discours de
combat pierre Gatas dénonce une
politique incohérente vous dites que le
cap est clair mais on a le patron du
MDEF qui dit que la politique est
totalement incohérente et d'ailleurs lui
aussi il voit comme de nombreux Français
c'est des hausses d'impôts derrière les
fameuses baisses de charges écoutez moi
ce que j'observe côté patronnal et sans
jeter la pierre à niapier Gatas NIF
c'est d'abord des une succession de
déclarations incohérent ça pour le coup
c'est sûr un coup c'est l'ISF qu'on
supprime un coup c'est tel dispositif du
droit social qui doit permettre de créer
soi-disant 200000 300000 emplois qu'on
ne voit jamais et plus généralement je
crois que certains partenaires sociaux
c'est vrai dans le monde syndical comme
dans le monde patronal quelque part sont
victimes d'une base de leur base d'une
partie de leur base qui dérape qui
dérape y compris qui est sensible à des
sirènes politique et idéologique pour
dire les choses très concrètement à des
formes d'extrémisme qu'ils ont du mal à
endiguer et certaines formulation entre
guillemets radical côté patronal comme
côté syndical doivent être pris comme
l'aveu que les patrons de syndicat
certains en tout cas ont de plus en plus
de mal à maîtriser une base qui devient
très vir mais là on parlait du patronat
vous parliez bien P patronat mais je ve
vous dire Monsieur Gatas ici quand on
l'entend dire il faut supprimer l'ISF il
faut abolir tout partie du code du
travail on considère que c'est un
dangereux droitier ultralibéral mais
certains patrons en province considèrent
que Monsieur Gatas c'est un gauchiste ah
bon mais évidemment vous avez des PME
des petites entreprise dans certains
territoires qui considèrent que Monsieur
Gatas est trop mou qui ne se bat pas
assez pour pour des donc ne sous-estimez
pas dans le monde patronal comme dans le
monde syndical une
radicalisation des
bases social de de de de ces
organisations qui traduit un état du
pays qui par ailleurs se manifeste en
vote Front national quand il y a des
élections donc on a vraiment un
glissement très profond de du sol sur
lequel reposent ces formations
politiques et alors là il y a deux
options il y a une option qui est en
gros la pente de ces dernières années je
parle pas seulement des nôres je parle
celle d'avant aros sur les forces
sociales
ils savent pas se tenir ils racontent
n'importe quoi ou il y a une deuxième
option qui est comment on on on réforme
le dialogue social pour que remettre en
situation des partenaires sociaux
solides de réencadrer leur leur base non
mais à propos de ce danger extrémiste
vous le dites dans le patronat notamment
est-ce que vous craignez donc la
mobilisation commune il y a toutes les
organisations le Medef la CGPME la
première semaine de décembre contre une
politique qui bride l'économie même s'il
vise une politique est à l'œuvre d'
depuis 30 ans est-ce que vous craignez
cette mobilisation avec même peut-être
des patrons dans la rue à la demande de
la CGP ce que je crains c'est c'est le
confusion la la confusion
généralisée il est probablement vrai que
on peut faire un peu plus pour soutenir
les entreprises dans tel ou tel domaine
mais au moment où les entreprises
bénéficient ce qui n'a jamais été le cas
dans l'histoire récente de la nation de
40 millions de baisses de cotisation
sociale et d'allègement d'impôts au au
moment où on on y reviendra tout à
l'heure on a a une uvre de
simplification que les patrons saluent
eux-mêmes sans précédent c'est pas bien
de dire on est les
victimes c'est c'est c'est pas de
l'ingratitude c'est plus grave que ça
c'est menés ces mandants ceux qui
donnent le mandat aux dirigeants de ces
organisation dans le mur c'est pas oui
c'est attisé finalement ça contribuera à
attiser des protestations alors que la
vraie réponse que Pierre Gatas est
victime des extrémismes en même temps il
va dans leur sens les encourage ben moi
je pense que la seule façon de ne pas
encour ager les extrémistes patronaux
comme syndicaux c'est de retrouver les
voies d'un vrai dialogue social
responsable mature et d'une relance de
la négociation d'accord mais en même
temps quand même tiimand donc quand on
regarde si on met la de côté
effectivement la polémique sur l'ISF
après tout pierre Gatas a toujours
dénoncé une aberration eu provocation a
répondu Emmanuel Macron mais on
s'aperçoit qu'il y a très peu de
différence dans le discours entre le
patron des patrons et le ministre de
l'Économie encore à Londres il y a
quelques heures ce dernier a proné des
dérogations multiples au 35 he il a
critiqué lui aussi le système
d'assurance trop
protecteur oui écoutez on va juger
Emmanuel Macron à ses actes et son
discours très pro business encore
plusiness quand il est à Londes comme
Manuel Vals d'ailleurs on va oui mais
quand on est à Londres on vend on vend
évidemment ce que les efforts que la
France fait pour restructurer son offre
c'est-à-dire soutenir ses entreprises on
va le juger aux actes ces actes sera la
grande loi qu'il prépare au mois de
février sur les professions réglementées
sur le travail du dimanche peut-être sur
une révision des des seuils sociaux
c'est à ce moment-là qu'on pourra juger
Emmanuel Macron et quelque chose me dit
que Monsieur Macron est beaucoup plus
complexe que ce qu'on pense c'est pas un
libéral échevelé à tout craint c'est
quelqu'un qui a une vision d'un nouvel
équilibre entre l'économique et le
social il considère qu'en effet il faut
donner un certain nombre de liberté pour
que l'économie respire plus pour que les
entreprises les petites notamment se
développe mais en même temps il croit à
un nouveau contrat social c'est-à-dire
que c'est pas sans contrepartie donc on
jugera aux actes attendons encore quel
d' on le juge quand même d'ors et déjà
par exemple la maèire socialiste de
Paris annie dalgo a déjà dit que il
était pas question qu'elle se laisse
prendre ses pouvoirs par Bery à propos
de l'ouverture des magasins le dimanche
alors il y a quand même une drôle
d'ambiance hein oui bah écoutez que
répondez-vous à la mère de Paris qui n'a
pas compris manifestement l'intérêt
d'étendre les zones touristiques pour
l'ouverture le dimanche écoutez je crois
pas une seconde que ça puisse être sa
position si si la M de Paris sait que
ouvrir un certain n il lui est arrivé de
contredire le chef de l'État sur les
Jeux Olympiques là sur l'ouverture des
magasins de dimanche je pense que
ministéomie défend des positions des
prérogatives des M face à l'état mais
elle elle sait pertinemment qu'un
certain nombre de grands magasins qui
serait ouvert le le dimanche qu'un
certain nombre de boutiques dans les
gare très fréquenté le dimanche ça
nuirait pas à l'économie parisienne et à
l'emploi à Paris donc c'est plutôt qui
décide de quoi et c'est une attitude de
maire face à un état qui veut faire
évoluer les réglementations d'accord il
faudra qu'il s'entende dans tous les cas
et vous dites Emmanuel Macron sera jugé
avec son texte ses réformes les Profion
réglementé et cetera au printemps en
février avec un enjeu très important
également c'est l'arrivée du Congrès du
Parti socialiste puisque finalement la
date a été fixée par Jean-Christophe
cambadellis c'est Karine per de lafp
arrive pour évoquer avec nous donc la
situation politique au PS qui est
divisée sur un certain nombre de sujets
division qui devrait s'étaler donc au
printemps lors de ce congrès ces enjeux
ces dangers avec Sandra
ckera trouver la date a été un
casse-tête 2016 était celle voulue par
l'exécutif pour obliger les socialistes
serrer les rangs avant la présidentielle
il n'en sera rien le Congrès PS organisé
en juin prochain sera celui d'un parti
déchiré mais pour Jean-Christophe
cambadéis pas question de parler de
division il se pose en rassembleur l'axe
du Congrès pour moi c'est la réussite de
la fin du quinquena les plus optimistes
sont convaincus que c'est la ligne
sociale libéral qui l'emportera mais
chez les réformateurs il y a aussi pas
mal de défétistes de fatalistes pour qui
l'implosion du parti semble inévitable
si le Parti socialiste se laisse aller
ou une disons une parti de ce parti
socialiste se laisse aller à cette
dérive critique bah alors on sera tous
perdant et donc et je ne vois pas
d'ailleurs comment on pourrait gagner
2017 dans ces conditions il faudrait que
les socialistes soient raisonnables le
seront-ils c'est une question l'aile
gauche du PS ne l'entend pas ainsi elle
veut en découdre et souhaite un congrès
aux air référendum sur la politique du
gouvernement un congrès qui arrive juste
après les départementales annoncé
calamiteuse pour les socialistes si les
Français devaient continuer à exprimer
une forme de désarroi ou de colère
finalement à l'égard de l'expérience de
la gauche au pouvoir telle qu'elle se
développe aujourd'hui je pense en effet
que le Président de la République
devrait à ce moment-là ouvrir un trè
temps de son quinquena en infléchissant
sa politique et s'il ne le fait pas le
congrès socialiste sera évidemment pour
les les militants en juin l'occasion de
dire ce qu'il pensent de tout cela
l'aile gauche du parti doit s'organiser
la principale inconnue se nomme Martine
Oubri ses proches l'assurent le
rassemblement ne se fera pas à n'importe
quel prix certains parlent de congrès de
clarification moi je pense que ça doit
être un congrès d'orientation qui doit
déterminer queles sont voilà comment
vont s'organiser les les dernières
années du quinena et comment on vaut
ouvrir la porte à un autre quinquena
sans inflexion de la politique du
gouvernement
François Lam pourrait être tenté de
devenir candidat à la tête du parti les
troupes de Martin auri particulièrement
active au sin des frondeurs pourrait
détenir la clé du Congrès
PS voilà donc sur tous ces sujets Karine
P nous a rejoint vos questions Karine
sur cette situation au psonso bonsoir
oui n'est-ce pas effarant quand on
regarde ce reportage de de voir un parti
dans un tel état alors que c'est le le
parti aux affaires bah vous avez raison
il y a deux façons de concevoir le parti
le Congrès du Parti socialiste qui n'est
pas l'événement qui va préoccuper le
plus les Français dans les semaines et
les mois qui viennent première façon
c'est un concours de tir à la corde ceux
qui se disent pigon Paris tire à la
corde tire à la corde ceux qui se
direent sociolliibéraux tir le plus
possible vers eux et ceux qui se disent
frondeur ou je sais pas beaucoup plus à
gauche que le gouvernement tire de leur
côté et laaccorde tire tire tire tire et
on espère et on prie encore une fois pas
les Français qui s'en fichent
complètement enfin nous pour que
laaccorde ne casse pas il y a une
deuxième façon moi je pense que c'est ça
le bon chemin de ce congrès pour qu'il
soit vraiment utile c'est de en effet
d'orientation d'un congrès d'orientation
de se poser les trois quatre questions
sur lesquelles les socialistes ne sont
pas claires aujourd'hui la première
question c'est la question de la
croissance est-ce qu'on ne vit pas avec
un mythe du retour de la
croissance 2 3 % durable qu'on ne verra
jamais plus moi j'ai cette conviction
j'ai cette conviction que on on vit avec
une représentation de la croissance que
ni vous ni moi ni nos enfants ne
connaîtront jamais plus que donc ça Mona
jusqu'à combien et pas plus on est le
débat existe on rentre pas on n pas le
temps de faire le débat existe aux
États-Unis aujourd'hui il y a des des
des grandes théories qui disait que le
potentiel de de gain de compétitivité
des nouvelles technologies qu'elles soi
numérique biotechnologie est comparable
à la deuxème révolution industrielle et
qui disent plutôt non ça veut dire que
il faut résoudre cette question
dramatique et essentiel comment on fait
pour maintenir des niveaux de protection
sociale importants santé retraite des
niveaux de dépens publiqu important avec
des croissances durablement Lim l'EMP
exactement Lim non mais ça c'est
beaucoup plus intéressant de savoir si
finalement on tire un peu plus à gauche
première question non mais je dis ça
parce que pour moi c'est ça le la
feuille de route du prochain congrès et
celle-là ça peut ça peut il peut y avoir
des oppositions mais ça c'est un vrai
service qu'on rend pays parce que c'est
un des problèmes majeurs du pays
deuxième problème dans le sentiment de
défiance à l'égard de la vie publique de
la vie politique dans le sentiment de
d'inefficacité de l'action publique
comment on reconstitue une action
publique plus efficace plus opérante qui
quand elle proclame des droits décide
des droits fait en sorte que ces droits
soient réels je rentre pas dans les
détails aussi mais comment on revertèbre
l'action publique troisième débat la
question de la démocratie on voit bien
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui ce qui se
passe c'est en résion les choses très
simplement on est en démocratie dite
représentative la la la demande de
participation directe des Français aux
décisions n jamais été aussi forte elle
est encouragée par le niveau d'élévation
culturelle par les nouveaux moyens de
technologie comment la vieille
démocratie représentatif fait plus
d'espace à des formes nouvelles de de
par
bre c'est c'est des sujets majeurs un
congrès qui répondra à ces questions
rendrait service au pays service
quelqu'un doit pouvoir rassembler exact
question dans un texte majoritaire et
rassembler l'ensemble du parti et alors
qui va qui va à vos yeux va pouvoir
rassemler ah moi j'espère bien que
Jean-Christophe calis va faire autre
chose que l'arbitre entre une a gauche
et une a droite du parti socialiste
c'est à lui de faire ça d'ailleurs il y
a aucune raison de penser qu'il se prête
par pas le faire en tout cas je souhaite
vivement qu'il se pose là-dessus
j'attends sa déclaration la première
option un parti divisé ne va pasésenter
le risque existe je suis lucide comme
vous j'entends même j'entends même les
si quelqu'un
ne dit pas que ce congrès pour être
utile et au socialistes et au pays doit
poser des questions majeures qui relève
en fait de de l'avenir de de la gauche
dans dans dans une démocratie comme la
nôtre si c'est simplement moi je suis
plus à gauche moi je suis plus à droite
le Congrès ça va ça sera pas un
référendum pour ou contre François
Hollande
Emmanuel on peut se demander si ce con
ne sera pas fatal au Premier ministre
non je je crois pas je je crois pas je
je vois pas pour quelle raison il le
serait je pense que le premier ministre
a une majorité très nette de par
parlementaire qui soutiennent on
n'imagine pas qu'il est les 91è du
groupe encore aujourd'hui pour fa voist
aussi au Parlement bien sûr mais qu'il
est une majorité très nette pour faire
voter un budget et que ceux qui votent
son budget parce qu'ils sont en congrès
votent le contraire il y a un principe
de cohérence et de responsabilité qui
j'espère animera tout le monde Martine
Aubri justement quel rôle voyez-vous
pour
elle Martine auri a plein de choses à
apporter sur les questions que j'ai posé
sur la question de la croissance durable
limitée et en même temps articulée avec
la protection sociale si elle est dans
une logique d'apport de contribution de
de la redéfinition d'une identité elle a
plein de choses à apporter si elle
participe au match des uns contre les
autres Mo moins il y aura de
protagoniste et mieux je me porterai sur
le match les uns contre les autres donc
elle doit pas rentrer dans ce ce ce
jeullà des gens qui ont cette stature ce
passé politique cette expérience
politique peut-être cette avenir
politique s'ils en décident ils doivent
contribuer à élever le débat pas le
l'abisser d'accord Emmanuel Vals aussi
selon vous est majoritaire lui qui a
fait les yeux doux à baayrou qui changer
le nom du parti
socialiste je sais pas comment il va
gérer le Congrès du Parti socialiste lui
il est chargé de diriger les affaires de
la France j'espère qu'il va regarder ça
avec le sérieux qu'implique une
réflexion des socialistes entre eux mais
en même temps la distance qu'implique
celui qui doit faire en sorte que on
redresse la situation économique et
sociale j'imagine qu'il aura mieux à
faire que de passer ses soirées dans les
dans les préos d'école à à défendre
telle ou telle motion donc je pense que
lui il dirige le pays il a besoin d'un
CAP pour les 10 an qui viennent pour les
10 ans qui viennent pas pour les 10 mois
qui viennent parce que ça on a la
feuille de route gouvernementale et elle
ne changera pas ce qui espèrent que ça
changera pourquoi vous dites les 10 ans
les 10 ans parce que le problème
aujourd'hui de l'identité de gauche dans
un pays comme le nôtre c'est des
questions encore une fois structurantes
j'en ai évoqué quelquesunes tout à
l'heure c'est des questions qui se
posent sur le long terme la question
croissance modèle de protection sociale
création d'emploi croissance limitée
c'est une question pour les 10 ans qui
viennent nous on doit y apporter des
réponses et d'autres forces politiques
doivent aussi y apporter des réponses
justement el Vals vous le voyez durer
jusqu'à la fin du quinquena moi j'ai le
sentiment qui s'inscrit dans la durée
euh je travaille avec lui puisque je
suis rattaché institutionnellement à lui
comme secrétaire d'État chargé de la
réforme de l'État nous sommes en train
de préparer un premier paquet de réforme
assez importante pour le mois de février
mars prochain donc à quelques semaines
du du Congrès et il travaille énormément
à ces questionslà ce qui montre bien
qu'il se projetteent dans l'avenir
gouvernemental mais si on regarde
justement par rapport à sa majorité par
rapport aux fondeur ù son son interview
il parle de cette fameuse maison des
progressistes qu'il voudrait créer
est-ce qu'il est vraiment est-ce qu'il
se pose comme un chef de la majorité il
fait voter tous ces textes pour
l'instant sans aucun artifice de
procédure il y a pas eu de 493 il y a
pas eu de vote bloqué c'est des faits
hein je je décris je sais pas si ça
durera longtemps mais aujourd'hui
donnons-lui acte que malgré l'identité
tout à fait particulière qui cherche à
incarner parfois et et même avec les
arrêts parce que il est comme ça manuel
vas il aime bien un petit peu poser des
actes net et carrés il fait voter tous
ses textes sans avoir jamais recours à
une motion de de procédure donc c'est le
patron de la majorité est-ce que vous ne
pensez pas pour revenir au Congrès que
ça va être aussi l'occasion pour ceux
qui s'opposent à la politique menée par
l'exécutif de de demander un autre
candidat que François Hollande est-ce
que vous vous seriez favorable à une
primaire alors moi la primaire pour moi
elle est indispensable pour quelle
raison pas pour faire du tir au pigeon
contre X ou Y ou pour écarter telle
candidature y compris celle du président
s'il réussissait son quincana qui
voulait se représenter elle est ind
ensable parce que particulièrement 2017
ce que vous ne réglez pas dans une
primaire vous le retrouvez au premier
tour de la présidentielle toutes les
problèmes de configuration politique que
vous n'avez pas réglé dans la primaire
la plus large possible y compris élarger
au vert vous les retrouverez dans le
premier tour de la présidentielle ça
veut dire que vous diminuez les forces
les capacités de la gauche à être
présente au deième tour de la
présidentielle il vaut mieux s'il y a
tro quatre personnes à gauche qui ont
envie d'être candidat il vaut mieux
qu'il s'affronte dans une primaire que
la primaire tranche et qu'il n'y ait
qu'un candidat à la présidentielle
plutôt que il y aura pas de primaire et
qu'on fasse comme on l'a fait en 2002 un
premier tour avec des candidats
multiples à gauche et résultat on n'est
pas au deuxième tour donc je plaide pour
la primaire donc une primaire avec les
écologistes élargi le plus largement
radicaux écologistes et tous ceux qui
voudront y participer VO les communistes
les communistes s'ils le veulent quelque
chose me dit que ce sera peut-être plus
difficile mais ici au Sénat je sais que
il y a des écologistes et de poids qui
considèent qu'il faut parti fr Hollande
pourrait en faire a franand ça serait
pas mais ce serait pas bizarre aux
États-Unis les primaires ça vient des
États-Unis quand un président sortant se
représente pour un nouveau mandat c'est
4 ans il y a élection primaire très
souvent c'est une élection primaire
allégée il y a très peu de candidats les
cocus sont beaucoup moins ant qu'il le
sont dans les dans les vraies élections
pr mais il y en a aussi pourquoi parce
que c'est une occasion de ressourcement
pour le président sorçant président
sortant aux États-Unis mais en France
c'est pareil il a quand même besoin de
faire quelques mois de de de de de de
campagne de retourner auprès des
français de de voilà il a besoin de ce
travail de ressourcement pour être
revitalisé il aura surtout besoin de
retrouver de la popularité là il va
partirs très non pour l'instant si
c'était aujourd'hui oui si c'était
aujourd'hui oui pas de résultat une code
de popularité à 15 % vous l'imaginez
dans une primaire dans c'est conditions
là aujourd'hui je sais pas quelle
décision il prendrait si c'était
aujourd'hui mais dans 2 ans qui vous dit
qu'il sera encore à 15 % qui vous dit
qu'on aura pas de résultat moi je suis
persuadé qu'on aura des résultats je
suis persuadé qu'on aura des résultats
économiques d'ici 2 ans et même avant et
que ça pour
and bil comm payer pas de mer et il
pourrare désigné en tout c'est ce que je
souhaite moi je suis ministre je
travaille à la réussite du quinen donc
l'emblème de la réussite du quen c'est
que François puisse représenter s'il ne
peut pas c'est qu'on pas réussi le quen
si on n pas réussi le quen on ira tous
au trou vousous dit que on IR tous au
trou les socialistes qui pensent se
refaire un avenir politique sur l'échec
de François Hollande franchement il
ferait bien de revenir l'histoire de la
5e République mais vous nous dites que
le quinen de gauche peut encore
s'achever sur une réussite en je le
crois je crois vraiment je pense qu'il
est en train de se passer des choses
qu'on ne voit pas suffisamment mais
qu'au plan macro-économique un certain
nombre de choses sont en train de se
mettre en place 1 €o qui baisse un baril
de pétrole qui baisse des taux d'intérêt
très bas des liquidités abondantes un
ralentissement de la rigueur au niveau
européen et que tout ça ça va payer dans
l'année 201 facteurs extérieurs à la
France il faut il faut prayer la
Providence tout fa bah que l'économie
française soit puissamment
internationalisée c'est pas une question
de Providence et que c'est la réalité
économique du monde dans lequel on vit
on est dans la mondialisation vous citez
que les facteurs extérieurs je pas tout
à fait les taux d'intérêt c'est pas des
facteurs extérieurs que je sache c'est
parce que la signature française est
toujours considérée comme une signature
de qualité que les taux d'intérêt sont
bas il a des pays européens qui
aimeraient avoir le taux d'intérêt alors
on parlait des partenaire de gauche
disit une primaire éventuellement avec
les écologistes enfin pour l'instant
pour les cantonnales de mars 2015 c'est
pas très bien parti pour les socialistes
les les
écologistes voilà montrre montrre les
muscles sont pas pas très empreint à
faire des des alliances les communistes
également il y a une sorte de font tout
sauf le PS bah la marie est pas très
avenante dans dans l'immédiia on n pas
une popularité non mais c'est la réalité
c'est dommage he mais on a une
popularité qui est pas terrible et des
résultats qui sont moyens voire moyen
moins donc tout le monde se dir
peut-être que on peut finalement tenter
notre chance tout seul parce que avec
les socialistes c'est quand même pas une
compagnie très très appétissante je
pense que ceux qui font ça se trompent
je pense que le corps électoral français
les Français ils jugent pas ils sont pas
dans la nuance ah bah tiens on va pas
voter socialistme mais tiens on va voter
écologist je pense pas que ça marchera
comme ça je pense que la gauche réussira
ensemble en tout cas la gauche de
gouvernement disons he je je mets de
côté l'extrême gauche réussira ensemble
ou échouera ensemble et pour réussir
ensemble intérêt à assumer ensemble les
difficultés de l'exercice du pouvoir
mais en même temps le bilan de
l'exercice du pouvoir h et justement par
rapport à ces deux échéances de 2015
mettre un congrès en plein milieu c'est
pas un peu risqué bah le problème c'est
qu'il y a des statuts euh ou bah oui et
donc vous avez deux solutions soit vous
les respectez soit vous les foulez au
pied et je pense que dans la période
d'absence de repère en tout cas de
manque de repère il a fallu résister à
la tentation de reporter oui oui oui oui
et ben écoutez même si ça coûte il y a
des règles de vie communes au Parti
socialiste donc à la majorité bah on s'y
tient voilà c'est sa ça peut c'est
difficile mais ça ça risque de de se
traduire dans les sûr bien sûr mais mais
fouler au pied des règles qu'on partage
collectivement ça aussi des conséquences
très lourd encore une fois dans une
manque de repère je pense qu'il faut se
tenir à des choses simples et des
repères précis avec donc ce congrès qui
aura lieu au cours de cette année qui
risque d'être difficile donc entre
congrès et résultats électoraux merci
beaucoup Karine perine Tarn arrive
maintenant pour évoquer notamment entre
autres votre révolution je le disais
tout à l'heure Thierry Mandon une
révolution porteuse d'économie d'abord
ce reportage de Cécile Siou vous êtes
dans le voilà la tour de contrôle de
l'ensemble du réseau international de
l'État c'est ici que se trouve désormais
le nouveau centre nerveux des systèmes
informatiques de l'État CAF sécurité
sociale centre des impôts chaque semaine
entre 150 et 200 services administratifs
se raccordent à ce réseau central
ce qui permettra à terme que les 17000
administration présentes sur le
territoire soit relié entre elles
jusqu'à présent ell dépendaient
uniquement de leur ministère de tutelle
jusqu'à maintenant on pouvait avoir 4
data center dans une même ville pour
chacun des ministère avec un seul
système d'information on ne construirait
plus qu'un seul data center dans une
même ville une manière de faire des
économies mais aussi de simplifier les
relations entre administration avant la
direction départementale des territoires
et la direction départementale de la
protection des populations pour se
parler devait repasser par Paris au lieu
d'aller de faire quelques mètres pour
parler au site au site voisin au sein du
même département un meilleur dialogue
entre administration qui pourrait aussi
révolutionner l'usage des servic publics
com que tu veux mettre ton mail pro sur
cette plateforme on développe une
application France Connect elle va
permettre aux administrations d'aller
chercher directement les informations
dont elles ont besoin sur les citoyens
dans le cas d'une démarche vous avez
différentes informations qui sont à
donner vous allez donner votre carte
d'identité vous allez donner votre avis
fiscal vous allez donné votre
composition familiale et cetera en fait
ces informations là elles sont détenues
déjà par une autre administration si moi
administration je connais votre identité
ça va être beaucoup plus simple d'aller
frapper à la porte de mon collègue et de
lui dire voilà pour cette personne j'ai
besoin de telle pièce justificative plus
simple pour les usagers aussi car pour
s'inscrire à la CAF déclarer ses impôts
ou encore demander et une place en
crèche il n'y aura plus qu'un seul
bouton et un seul identifiant en gros
avec France Connect avec le bouton vous
arrivez identifier sur le site donc le
le
site peut vous proposer des services
personnalisés des servicees
personnalisés à l'avenir plus rien sur
vous n'échappera à l'administration même
si le gouvernement affiche un tout autre
objectif faire des économies il annonce
d'ors et déjà des chiffres ambitieux 14
à 16 milliards de d'ici à
2017 voilà pine d'na est avec nous
bonsoir pine alors on a envie d'en
savoir plus après ce reportage
évidemment sur sur Big Brother de
l'administration française un peu Big
Brother Michel bonsoir Thierry Mondon
Michel est très inquiet il a peur d'être
complètement fiché al est que sous
prétexte d'économie c'est big brow il
faut le rassurer non pas du tout d'abord
ce ce ce projet
extraordinaire qui qui consiste
finalement à ce que un Français ne fasse
qu'une fois les démarches qui le
concernent et qu'après ça se fasse
automatiquement pour pour toutes les
administrations y compris les mairies
compris les départements ce projet là il
est travaillé avec la knil la Commission
Nationale Informatique et Liberté qui
passe son temps dans les bureaux que
vous êtes allé
judicieusement visiter qui passe son
temps pour vérifier que il y a pas de
risque pour les données en tout cas il y
en a beaucoup moins pas de rutilisation
abusive de ces données là exactement que
il y en a beaucoup moins que quand on
utilise un moteur de recherche chez soi
quel qu'il soit mais il y avait déjà un
service qui existait pourtant de
regroupement administratif de de nos
données qui s'appelait monservice.com
quelque chose comme ça et ça c'est
abandonné il devait pas être très
efficace parce que ça a échappé quand
même à la plupart des Français he que ce
service existait là là c'est un travail
considérable h mise en place fin 2016
qui révolutionne tout le rapport entre
les Français et les administrations et
vous parez toujours sur une dizaine de
milliards d'euros d'économie à la clé et
d'ici à quel terme alors là vous parlez
de la simplification de la
simplification tout à fait d'ici fin
2016 je m'engage enfin je je m'engage
tout ça avec des chiffres validés au
niveau international les modèles de
calcul utilisés en Angleterre et en
Allemagne validés par le CDE à 11
milliards d'économies avéré sur les
politiques de simplification pour les
budgets des entreprises des
collectivités de l'administration 11
milliards donc ça on espère arriver à 14
16 donc ça c'est le choc de sûr c'est le
choc de simplif de simplif comme vous
choc de simplification pour les
entreprise pour les particuliers pour
les associations est-ce que vous faites
vous pouvez faire des économies avec
votre système informatique parce que
vous pouvrez peut-être plus facilement
traquer les fraudeurs en croisant tous
les fichiers on se réfère au reportage
alors il y a deux choses il y a les
économies de dépenses et il y a des
recettes supplémentaires économie de
dépenses oui dans le reportageétait très
bien dit ce qu'on appelle le Cloud
c'est-à-dire finalement il les Data
SYNTER c'est-à-dire le stockage des
données aujourd'hui chaque ministère
avait son système de stockage ça coûtait
très cher grâce à la nouvelle
organisation informatique qu'on a mis en
place on a cassé la responsabilité de
chaque ministre sur son informatique
pour faire une responsabilité unique au
niveau du Premier ministre donc il y a
plus qu'un système de stockage des
données les les les les la sécurité ça
coûte un peu d'investissement c'est
remboursé sur 3 années et la durée de
vie moyenne des équipements c'est 15
années donc ça fait 12 années de rentab
de de dépenses en moins donc assez
importante et puis deuxièmement vous
avez raison on était dans une aberration
mais ça c'est très important de le dire
vous aviez un logiciel aux finances
publiques un logiciel aux douanes pour
la TVA qui était pas compatible donc
vous ne pouviez pas jusqu'à maintenant
voir les fraudes à la TVA désormais on
pourra les identifier quand les Anglais
ont fait ça il y a 4 ans ils ont mis 50
millions de logiciels nouveaux pour
rendre vraiment opérable les deux
systèmes et ça leur apporté la première
année 5 milliards 50 millions 5
milliards donc dans la chasse au fausse
déclaration donc ça veut dire que vous
investissez un peu mais ça rapporte
beaucoup de recettes nouvelles grâce à
la chasse au fraudeurs donc he grâce à
l'identification des fr des des
spécialistes de de ce genre de de de
comportement donc vous êtes le ministre
des bonnes nouvelles hein V poste doit
être plutôt envé au gouvernement non
c'est compliqué à mettre en place et à
faire bouger toutes les administration
qui sont assis sur leur territoire assis
sur le
territoire est-ce que cette
simplification vous l'appliquez aussi à
votre propre ministère dans dans son
fonctionnementout
oui on essaye alors nous on je vais vous
parler très directement d'abord je suis
arrivé tard moi dans l'équipe
gouvernementale je suis arrivé en en
juin dernier donc je suis en CDD de très
court terme euh sauf si on Premier
ministre a marre de moi rapidement mais
de toute façon il nous reste moins de 3
ans donc on est obligé de s'organiser
comme une mission c'est long déjà pour
un CDD hein vous le savez ouais mais
enfin les politiques de simplification
en Angleterre ça a commencé il y a 10
ans ils ont pas fini en Allemagne 9 ans
ils ont pas fini donc on est organisé en
effet de manière très débureaucratisée
open space donc on a une équipe qui qui
travaille ensemble parce que cétait trop
poussireux le fonctionnement du
ministère mais parce que c'est parce que
si vous voulez franchement onvie est
dans 2 1e siècle à l'air du numérique
donc à l'air de l'horizontalité de la
vitesse de circulation des informations
pour créer et que quand vous êtes obligé
de prendre rendez-vous avec quelqu'un
pour aller le voir de pousser son bureau
puis après de prendre un autre
rendez-vous dans le bureau d'à côté pour
pour faire avancer un dossier vous
perdez un temps considérable si vous
mettez tout le monde dans le même dans
le même bureau avec une des aménagements
qui permettent bah vous gagnez un temps
considérable mais toutes les entreprises
de France sont vous-même probablement
sont déjà dans C donc c'est c'est
nouveau pour l'administration mais
finalement c'est qu'une session de
rattrapage il a grosse innovation allez
on avance un petit peu sur les questions
d'actualité l'UMP qui rouvre le débat
autour du mariage pour tous et Nicolas
Sarkozy qui divise au sein même de son
propre camp sur le mariage homosexuel
est-ce que vous avez compris vous ce
weekend le revirement de l'ancien chef
d'État moi j'ai appris ce weekend j'ai
j'ai trouvé qu'on assistait au naufrage
d'un chef
euh quelqu'un
qui a fait toute sa carrière en disant
moi je suis un sacré bonhomme je décide
j'ai peur de rien j'ai peur de personne
les gens peuvent protester dans la rue
moi quand j'ai décidé j'ai décidé il eu
peur de la salle samedi et là il arrive
dans dans un sous-courant de l'UMP VO il
il dit en gros ce qu'il pense il voit
que ça hurle il change de position
vraiment j'ai eu le sentiment qu'on
assistait au nufrage d'un chef je pense
que Nicolas Sarkozi s'est révélé être
n'être plus ce qu'il affirmait qu'il
était c'est-à-dire un patron et un chef
vous savez qu'il va être quand même élu
à la présidence de l'UMP a priori sauf
surprise donc le naufrage dans vot tête
nous verrons nous verrons il peut être
élu à la la présidence de l'UMP et
emmener son organisation un peu comme
les les les les éléphants qui vont au
cimetière emener toute la troupe avec
lui et vous vous avez le sentiment que
la droite ne reviendra jamais sur ce
texte mariage pour tous bah écoutez moi
je déjà je regarde les réactions de ceux
qui sont soi-disant les soutiens de
Nicolas Sarkozi depuis 48 heur qui
explique tout que c'est à quelques
exceptions près que ça n'est pas
faisable de revenir là-dessus ouais vous
avez été élu de lesson Serge d'assau
aujourd'hui est à nouveau mise en cause
pour des remises d'argent en liquide
est-ce qu'il doit démissionner de son
mandat de
sénateur c'est difficile de parler de
vous proche géographiquement non mais
géographiquement il m'est proche mais
enfin ça fait quand même quelques mois
qu'il a des procédures est- qu' peut
rester qui sont
convergentes il est en examen il a
pasêtre sénateur je ne sais pas la
contribution qui la porte à l'œuvre
législative au Sénat il est assez
présent faut le reconnaître présent
certes mais j'ai pas eu le sentiment que
pour l'instant il avait été déterminant
dans les choix de cette assemblé je
pense qu'il serait bien de concentrer
sur sa défente donc en effet de
d'éventuellement passer la main mais
c'est à Lui qui appartient cette
décision ouais il y a une nouvelle
apparition aujourd'hui de Thomas tevenou
à l'Assemblée nationale en commission il
a pris la parole et il y a plusieurs
députés socialistes qui ont quitté cette
salle de de commission est-ce que vous
vous auriez fait la même chose oui oui
moi je suis pour qu'onurcissent les
moyens de lutte contre les comportements
quasi dé d'un certain nombre de
parlementaires la semaine dernière trois
parlementairesp mais peu importe ça
aurait pu être chez nous ont été ont
été traduit signalé par la Haute
Autorité de la transparence de la vie
publique à la justice comme ayant des
comptes à l'étranger je pense qu'il faut
premièrement donner plus de moyens à
cette autorité plus de moyens ça va et
l'enquête là elle arrive à elle a besoin
d'aller plus vite plus fort elle doit
avoir accès au à ce qu'on appelle
trackfin c'està-dire tout tout
l'administration qui trace la corruption
internationale les mouvements de fond
elle doit pouvoir échanger plus
facilement les données avec les impôts
qu'elle ne fait aujourd'hui elle doit
même avoir plus de moyens humains c'est
indispensable donc un système préventif
donc 1 an après sa création le bilan est
insuffisant vous trouvez il il est bon
mais cette instance qui a fait ses
preuves toutes les affaires qui sortent
sont des affaires qui qui qui qui
sortent grâce à elle doit être avoir des
moyens renforcés et deuxiè sera le il
faut être ces moyens vont être renforcés
je le crois je crois c'est indispensable
vous nous l'annoncez en fait et je le
crois vivement et deuxièmement il faut
être impitoyable implacable pardon sur
ceux qui ont fauté avec l'argent public
alors on nous explique il y a pas le le
droit pénal empêche de dire si les gens
peuvent pas sont inéligibles à vie très
bien enfin moi je suis pour des peines
d'inégibilité très longue voyez quand on
a pris dans le pot de confiture quand on
s'est mal comporté qu'on est
gestionnaire de l'argent public on doit
débarrasser la vie publique de sa
présence pendant une dizaine d'années et
en même temps il y a une Grunne qui
monte ch parlementaire sur notre site
internet publicsena.fr un sénateur UMP
parle de régime de guestapo en parlant
de la Haute Autorité mais
guestapou guestapou les déclarations
sont publiques il y a rien de scandaleux
dans les les compte en Suisse que
certains retrouvent par héritage
par ils retrouvent comme ça par hasard
et ils avaient oublié de les déclarer au
fisque les pauvres je comprends que ils
se sentent pour chasser alors il y aux
il y a par exemple
le nouveau président du
groupe qui lui réclame la démission
d'office des parlementaires en cas de
fraude fiscale avéré ça c'est une
initiative que vous soutenez donc en
tout cas je sais pas j'ai noté qu'il
avait évolué je crois dans sa
formulation depuis quelques jours et que
il avait fait une petiqu au sénateur
qui moi je suis pour des sanctions très
dures quand les faits sont avérés quand
ils ont été en justice condamné donc là
c'est trop tôt pour les
parlementaires
condam que non seulement ils doivent
payer les amendes nécessaires mais il
doit y avoir des peines d'inégibilité de
longue durée proclamé en même temps mais
vous nous annoncez donc que la Haute
autorité pour la transparence va avoir
ses moyens renforc j'pè vivement elle
elle doit l'être elle doit avoir est-ce
que c'est une position qui est partagée
par le Premier ministre avec qui vous
travaillez directement vous n l'zion de
parler de ça avec lui mais je sais que
le bil premier bilan de la Haute
Autorité est plutôt considéré comme
positif et qu'en effet s'il faut qu' a
plus de moyens pour agir on lui donnera
plus et à votre connaissance est-ce
qu'il y aura d'autres signalements parce
que il y a encore des je suis pas dans
les
confidan c'est prob en tout cas c'est
probable en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que donnons acte à ce gouvernement
président Premier ministre que il
n'entrave aucune affaire de financement
occulte de vie publique qui sort qui que
ce soit qui soit concerné élu de gauche
ou élu de droite et quand on parlait de
présidence normal on a beaucoup moqué le
président pour cette formulation mais il
voulait dire ça aussi voulez dire qu'il
y a des comportements qui sont désormais
inadmissibles et qui doivent être
sanctionnés et la justice doit passer il
a fau pour cela l'affaire kusac oui
prière et puis après les affaires tVous
et puis d'autres affaires et et en effet
ce mouvement est salutaire très bien
merci beaucoup monsieur Mandon merci
pine bonsoir à tous à très vite et la
semaine prochaine nous serons au Congrès
des maires en direct du Congrès des
M